يسمع جيدًا تطورًا محتملاً للغاية
في روسيا حيث يقاتل طبيب
انتقد عدم وجود معدات واقية
في مستشفاه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للبقاء على قيد
الحياة بعد سقوطه
من نافذة الطابق الثاني.
في مدينة فيرونا زه
الآن في حالة خطيرة مع
إصابات في الرأس وفقًا لتقارير وسائل الإعلام المحلية في
وقت سابق ، فقد تم تشخيص إصابته
بفيروس كورونا ونشر
رسائل متحديًا عبر الإنترنت تقول إنه
أُجبر على العمل بعد أن تأكدت
إصابته بالشرطة.  يجري التحقيق
معها لنشرها أخبار كاذبة وبدا أنها
تراجعت في وقت لاحق عن تعليقاته قبل أن
تغرق من النافذة في ظروف غامضة ،
أخبر أحد زملائه
شبكة CNN أنه كان يستعد
للخروج من المستشفى حيث
كان يتلقى العلاج من
إصابته بفيروس كورونا.  بينما أثار
الكثير من القلق على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أنه الطبيب الروسي الثالث
الذي سقط من الريح  في الأسابيع الأخيرة في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر في مدينة كراسنويارسك السيبيرية توفيت متأثرة بجروحها بعد سقوطها خلال اجتماع مع مسؤولي الصحة المحليين.تقول وسائل الإعلام المحلية إن الطبيبة كانت تعارض تغيير مستشفاها إلى منشأة لفيروس كورونا مرة أخرى بسبب نقص معدات الحماية على الرغم من أصدرت وزارة الصحة الإقليمية بيانًا نفت فيه وفاة رئيس الخدمات الطبية في ستار سيتي ، وهي قاعدة التدريب الرئيسية لرواد الفضاء الروس ، الشهر الماضي بعد سقوطه من نافذة ، ووصفتها السلطات هناك بأنها حادث مأساوي لكنها لم تذكر مزيدًا من التفاصيل. نحن نعلم أن نظام الرعاية الصحية في روسيا والطاقم الطبي الذي يعمل فيه يتعرضون لضغوط متزايدة حيث يجتاح جائحة فيروس كورونا البلاد فرصة ماثيو سي إن إن